all right everybody let's wrap things up
with something really sweet I found on
social media this is what I'm
liking okay so check out this painting
it's by an amazing new artist the thing
is he doesn't use brushes he doesn't use
a roller or pallet knives what he does
is totally unconventional let's get him
on the line right now to explain
everyone say hi to Mac and let's bring
in his human companions his partner
Corporal Kevin Henderson and the founder
of friends of the K9 bestest Midwest and
oh my gosh so youall got to explain like
how did this start like did he always
love painting and then it became a
fundraising thing explain how this all
started um so I created Friends of the
K9 vest Midwest back in 2020 um for my
love of law enforcement and dogs in
general I've been in rescue for over 25
years now and I just found out that
these lot of dogs are working without
vests and they need vests and they need
food and they need medical attention
they need retirement packages um they
need get well baskets they need all
kinds of things with these four-legged
Heroes that we have and I was like we
need to come up with a really cool way
to fund raise and um so we came up with
uh this concept where the dogs get to be
the picassos and we' even had one of our
paintings go for $2,000 so it's a fun
and great way for us to raise money to
do what we need to do for these Kines oh
my God it is hard not to just keep your
eyes on Mac he is adorable so so Ma has
made a few paintings right yeah so I
worked with Emily for years and he's
made several just trying to raise money
uh to get these vests for all these dogs
we've been able to get vests for all
three of our agency dogs through Emily
uh main thing is just trying to keep the
dogs safe as possible when they're out
working uh they're put in very dangerous
situations and uh they're very good dogs
and they deserve everything they can get
absolutely oh my God that tongue hanging
out his mouth I mean I just love him so
much thank you so much Emily Corporal
Kevin and Mac I am liking your post
right now this is such a cool thing to
do and a cool way to fundraise uh that's
not all though everybody our season long
partner pilot pin makers of G2 the go-to
pin of the Kelly Clarkson show want to
support dogs putting themselves at risk
on the front lines so they're going to
be writing a check to friends of the K9
vest Midwest for $1,000 how's that
sound awesome a thank you guys so much
for your service thank you to all our
guests this hour Billy Ray Cyrus fire
Rose Sam J Christy Co Arian langsom and
Marcy BAC you know what have a great day
everybody if it's not try and change
[Applause]
[Music]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home